pues a las tres y media de la tarde diez
y media de la mañana hora de bogotá
quito y lima retomar a la sesión de alto
nivel en la que participarán ministros o
representantes de los países cuyos jefes
de gobierno o de estado no hablaron
durante la cumbre de líderes del primero
y 2 de noviembre va a haber bastante
actividad latinoamericana entre ellos el
canciller de nicaragua y los ministros
de medio ambiente de guatemala uruguay
el salvador perú y paraguay también
hablará el ministro de ambiente de haití
y grandes actores en la posible lucha
climática como lo es rusia que solo
mandó a uno de sus diez viceprimeros
ministros como bien lo decía soy la
temática es doble por un lado el género
como regular o quitar la inequidad de
las mujeres o la inequidad
representativa porque las mujeres están
subrepresentados siempre en las
negociaciones climáticas y nosotras
somos las que más sufrimos los efectos
de esta crisis climática por otro lado
como bien lo mencionabas también raúl
está el tema de la ciencia y la
innovación
como las soluciones como la ciencia y
las innovaciones tecnológicas pueden ser
la solución para frenar esta crisis
climática y mantener las temperaturas a
niveles adecuados para poder seguir
viviendo de manera digna y seguir
adaptándonos a este clima cambiante en
el que estamos sumidos así que una
agenda bastante apretada para el día de
hoy con temas de peso como todos los
días de la semana aquí en la competición